jacques chirac good du mont d'or en
buvant du vin du jura une image typique
pour celui qui est souvent venu en
franche comté
l'homme politique a effectué de nombreux
voyages dans notre région où il a serré
beaucoup de mains et donner de
nombreuses monde
je n'ai jamais pu résister en 87 jacques
chirac premier ministre est accueillie
par le maire socialiste de besançon
robert schwint à l'hôtel de ville
il évoque deux dossiers importants le
grand canal j'ai reçu les informations
nécessaires entre le gars est maintenant
de ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec sa
réalisation
je n'ai trouvé personne d'ailleurs
encore qu'il soit tout à fait d'accord
ou en tous les cas qui ose le dire ou en
tous les cas qui ose le dire
et il promet le tgv ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il sera réalisé
je suis incapable de vous dire
aujourd'hui la date mais on ne peut pas
dire que il recule on peut dire qu'ils
n'avancent pas ce sujet on peut dire
qu'il n'avance pas suffisamment vite
campagne présidentielle de 95 dans cette
voiture entre vesoul et besançon
il apprend par téléphone portable une
nouvelle qui va changer sa vie
pour la première fois un sondage le
donne devant l'autre candidat de droite
edouard balladur il est élu président de
la république trois mois plus tard
réunion publique ce soir là à besançon
en gelant les salaires en cessant de
récompenser le travail comme il le
mérite
justement ont des règles ray du même
coup les ressorts de la croissance et de
l'emploi et on fabrique créer du chômage
c'est justement le président de la
république qui est accueillie aux bains
douches à montbéliard lors d'un voyage
en 96 dans notre région le soir au
banquet où sont conviés tous les
politiques de la région
même les élus de gauche le juge
sympathique sympathique mais pas que
président du rpr ministre candidat à la
présidentielle premier ministre
président de la république
tous saluent aujourd'hui le parcours
exceptionnel de l'homme qui a marqué la
vie politique de la france durant 50 ans
[Applaudissements]